Netflix's daredevil is a rumor to be
entering the MCU very soon and the movie
that he is rumored to be entering in is
spider-man 3 how's it going everyone
it's Warren and spider-man far from home
was a massive success it's already doing
extremely well for a Tuesday release and
people have already begun to look
forward what is next for spider-man well
with all of the events that happened in
spider-man far from home and a little
bit of timing on Netflix and Marvel's
part it seems like everything is lining
up for daredevil to make his appearance
in the MCU in spider-man 3 it does seem
like everything has lined up perfectly
for daredevil to make his appearance in
the next spider-man film so I'll break
everything down in this video real quick
if you would like a chance to win a
Captain America shield an Iron Man
helmet an Infinity Gauntlet or another
Marvel Legends item be sure to subscribe
to my channel I'm doing a giveaway at
four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers I'll be picking three new
winners so president of Marvel Studios
Kevin Feige has recently come out and
talked about using the Netflix Marvel
characters in the MCU in a recent
interview with ve t-dot-com Kevin Feige
was asked of the Netflix Marvel heroes
which one would you be most excited to
get into a movie first in which Kevin
Feige replied I don't know there were a
lot of great characters that were on
those Netflix series and I think there
is a period of time it'll be awhile
before we could use any of them based on
what the contracts were so I'm not sure
and also even answering that question is
a spoiler but there are some great
Marvel characters there so Kevin Feige
says that it could be a while before we
see them but then he says that answering
the question could be a spoiler hmm I'll
get back to that in just a second but in
regards to this contract and using the
Netflix characters in the MCU they could
use daredevil in 2020 daredevil was
cancelled in 2018 and according to a
report from variety.com Netflix and
Marvel / Disney had a deal worked out to
where if a show was canceled the
characters in the shows could not be
used by Disney or Marvel for two years
after the cancellation well daredevil
again was cancelled in 2018 which means
he is available to be used in 2020 and
if Marvel continues to release a new
solo spider-man film every two years
that means the next spider-man film
would get spider-man three would come
out in 2021 which means daredevil would
be available to use in spider-man three
and they would have plenty of time to
film and daredevil is actually the
perfect hero to bring into spider-man 3
for those of you who have not seen
spider-man far from home yet I am about
to talk about the post-credits scene of
the movie so you should click away now
if you want to avoid all spoilers
however I'll do my best not to spoil
anything about the movie in the
post-credits scene for spider-man fire
from home Mysterio has manipulated and
edited a video of the final battle that
makes it seem like Spiderman attacked
him and a bunch of people this video
gets broadcasted to essentially the
whole entire world via the Daily Bugle
and the news not only that but Mysterio
revealed that spider-man is in fact
Peter Parker so it seems like in the
next spider-man film Peter is probably
going to need a lawyer
enter Matt Murdock aka daredevil a
lawyer and superhero that could help
spider-man out in many different ways
not just legally but also fighting
villains and Hell's Kitchen where
daredevil is from is right around the
corner from where spider-man is so the
timing of everything seems to be lining
up just perfectly and introducing
daredevil could introduce some major
villains that daredevil and spider-man
have in common as spider-man and
daredevil have a long history together
in the comics and this could be an
opportunity to finally introduce kingpin
into the MCU which brings us back to
what Kevin Feige said about him even
mentioning who he would like to see in
the MCU could be a spoiler again he said
due to contracts it could be some time
until we see a Netflix character in the
MCU but then he said that if he
mentioned who he'd like to see it could
be a spoiler well perhaps it's a spoiler
because if fans have figured out that
daredevil could be used in the next
spider-man film what she can be then
it'll give away the fact that daredevil
could be making an appearance in the MCU
in spider-man 3 and we could be getting
kingpin as the next main villain of
course this is all just speculation and
rumors right now but everything does
seem to line up perfectly with what
Kevin Feige said and with the contract
for the Netflix characters so be sure to
comment with what you think about
daredevil possibly entering the MCU in
the next spider-man film also be sure to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain liked the video and subscribe to
my channel
so you can enter my giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof